i'll call the hearing to order good
morning everyone
hope you all had a good trip the sun is
shining can't complain so
our first bill is
sb
uh
senator regina
birdsall
welcome
welcome thank you
um for the record my name is
senator regina bertsell i represent the
towns of
derry hampstead in windham
and i am the prime sponsor of senate
bill 227
which is basically um death benefits for
for first responders who die from
suicide
um this was a bill that has
we've been working on i chaired the
commission on
[Music]
ptsd in first responders
this is one that we had worked on last
year this is one of the topics we had
worked with
some of the first responders last year
and this bill is primarily a result of
that commission
and i know there isn't
the amount of money that would
would be spent is um to me not a lot
when you consider the lives of
our first responders
as well as um what we did it we amended
it in the senate to include our
corrections officers in there
so with that i'll answer any questions
any questions from the committee members
seeing none thank you senator thank you
have a great day
thank you senator birdsall i needed a
pen
okay
um
we now call on uh david goldstein
good morning madam chair with your
permission i'll bring my colleagues with
me sure in the interest of time etc
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
david goldstein i'm the chief of police
in the city of franklin i've been chief
there for 13 years i've been a police
out excuse me i've been a chief for 18
years in a former
jurisdiction and i've been a police
officer for more than 42 years
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
with my pedigree
other than to tell you that i have an
extensive research
experiential and academic experience in
this area
i do chair the legislative committee for
the new hampshire association of chiefs
of police and we are in favor of this
bill sb227fn
uh
very briefly both research and clinical
experience dictate
the fact that there is a definite nexus
between and among the stress crisis and
trauma that all first responders
experience and the suicide among our
brothers and sisters
at present in law enforcement for
example
we estimate a one to four and a half
ratio of line of duty deaths to suicidal
deaths in police work in other words for
every one line of duty death and police
work there's at least four and a half
and i'm not sure how we uh rationalize
the half but there's at least 4.5 police
officers that will die by their own hand
there is a lack of
analog in other professions for this
it's important to note
that we are unaware of any suicide
and i am
being uh involved in this work for over
40 years i'm unaware of any suicide
among any first responder
as a cash incentive to kill him or
herself
i understand that this is a fiscal note
we don't have an amount we hope that we
never will have an amount
but should we we feel that this is the
right thing to do for the survivors of
anyone uh who does uh kill themselves as
a
member of the first responder family
with that
madam chair members of the committee
just as a means of introduction my name
is uh justin bretton i'm the mental
health and wellness coordinator for the
manchester new hampshire police
department i'm here this morning on
behalf of the new hampshire police
association to echo the sediments and
support that chief goldstein just laid
out for you for sb 227 fn
i am the mental health and wellness
coordinator for the manchester police
department and chief goldstein and i
co-coordinate
the new hampshire peer support network
that we are working diligently to create
excuse me
you have to speak into the microphone
because it is being um
the outside world can't hear you so
ma'am thank you thank you very much
sorry about that no problem
um so as i was saying we are here today
to voice our support
for this bill
unequivocally we hope that we will never
have to substantiate a cost to the state
the first responder community to include
corrections officers are working
diligently day in and day out
to make sure that we're providing our
personnel with the training and
resources available to be able to
mitigate this concern
but as a culture and as a state we are
playing catch-up
we have to do a better job of making
sure that we are taking care of those
who take care of others and this is a
very important first step
in that process
so i'd like to thank you all for your
time in consideration and if you have
any questions we'd be happy to answer
in fact we invite questions
thank you are there any questions from
thank you uh what is your name again
my name is justin bretton
b-r-e-t-o-n madam chair
i should have done this beginning i do
have some uh information for the
committee okay if you would pass it to
mr hoffman who's behind you
he'll take care of it thank you
representative
okay thank you madam chairman uh chief
ghosting a question for you you
mentioned a ratio of one to four four
and a half
this uh
the numbers you gave us are for people
who are actively on duty
is there a ratio when people are retired
because the reason i ask that is for the
va for example
as time progresses as veterans age it
becomes more of an issue
i wish that they were representative the
sad thing is that we do not know what's
happening among our uh retired
individuals other than through anecdote
uh there's actually very little research
in the area uh there's there may be some
clinical uh information available to us
but on a death certificate it doesn't
say
died by suicide because he was a cop so
to speak uh and we don't know we suspect
it's a very large number
um but again i can't give you a
definitive answer i wish i could okay
thank you chief you're welcome
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much i
appreciate your testimony thank you
thank you can i keep the dog
[Laughter]
representative steve pearson
thank you madam chair thank you members
of finance
for allowing me to speak
in front of you today
this is a
very personal bill for me and i'll get
into a little bit as
briefly as to why that is
um along with senator bertel i also sit
on the state's
ptsd
commission and we have been working
diligently every month
for quite some time on this topic
the reason that this bill in particular
is so personal to me is that i have two
working partners that have committed
suicide
now
working partners right so i've been in
the fire service for 27 years i've been
a manchester fire lieutenant and been on
manchester fire for the last 18 years
i've also served in the town of raymond
in new hampshire
and
the
the rarity of the these events
are
thank god they are as rare as they are
but to have two working partners go
through this is it's unusual for someone
to have one that that did it much less
too
um they were for
[Music]
certainly different reasons different
background situations but
one of the things that
unfortunately is
is difficult in the first responder
world as with a lot of things that's
cumulative so
you have horrific situations that occur
and
you know everyone handles those
differently and and you can have
situations over your career that
happened a decade ago and all of a
sudden they just pop up
so
you know this this is not always just a
simple causal relationship in the sense
of
x happened
y occurred
and z was the end result it
it it almost never works out that way so
um you know one of the things that
as you are a
the finance committee
you know we do have a peculiar fiscal
note here
in that
hopefully nothing ever happens and we
pay
zero dollars but the reality is that's
probably not the case and
you know we really should look at at the
holistic situation here with that
a hundred thousand dollar line of duty
death benefit in this particular case
is relatively peanuts considering that
all of the folks that are involved in
this are in the penn state pension
system
and
having been on edna for a couple of
terms and and having that is
kind of our
one of the major things that we we
tackle in edna i can tell you that
without getting into any of the math and
the formulas and the weeds of this
that for the family of the person that
goes through this this is a substantial
financial loss to them
to lose someone who's in the state
pension system that commits suicide
because this has long-term
ramifications the way the pension's
adjusted for survivors and i'm i know
that was mentioned by the the two
gentlemen that were here prior and i
really do want to harp on that in the
fact that there really truly is zero
financial incentive for this it's really
a financial train wreck for those that
are left behind
so you know not not getting into the too
much of the policy i just like i said
with you being financed i really do want
to harp on that
but i also do want to plug the
commission a little bit further here in
the sense that all of the aspects of
this have been looked at by the
commission we've we've dived into this
in
from angles that i didn't even think
were
were part of this and having a group
that is made up of folks from everything
from the insurance carriers to health
care to
social
certainly the legislative side of this
you know we've
we've looked at this from from many
different angles and it really truly is
a very complex situation so
you know that's that's something the
commission is really handling and you
folks are are here to decide whether or
not this
that the senate was right in passing
this in essence so
i ask for your support for this
i certainly encourage any of you if you
have specific questions to reach out to
to any anyone that's on the commission
um and we would be certainly able to
either answer it for you or get you to
the right person that specializes in
what your concern is
so i thank you
thank you are there any questions from
i now call on mr john mcallister
good morning
just once perfect there we go you can
all hear me now i apologize for that
thank you for the opportunity this
morning to testify in support of senate
bill 227.
for the record my name is john
mcallister and i serve as a secretary
treasurer of the professional
firefighters in new hampshire and i'm a
22-year member of the city of nashville
fire department
the professional the professional
firefighters of new hampshire have
submitted written testimony this morning
so um that's being handed out as we
speak
as a leading firefighter organization in
new hampshire the professional
firefighters in new hampshire
advocates for the health and safety of
the brave men and women who protect the
citizens of this great state
in the fire service we are routinely
called the scenes of catastrophic
incidents involving severe injuries
tragic loss of human life and property
loss
it is well documented that the effects
of these exposures over time
may result in psychological injuries and
even suicide
tragically we continue to see too many
of our brothers and sisters lose their
battles with post-traumatic stress
disorder
oftentimes this results in an increase
in harmful behaviors
including substance abuse self-harm or
suicide
we face the harsh reality that despite
our best efforts at awareness and
prevention our desk
or despite our attempts to provide a
listening ear or helping hand or a
shoulder to cry on there are simply more
instances where we are unable to
make the save of our own members
it is in these instances that our
responsibility then turns to the
families of the loved ones
these are the families who have left who
are left in the wake of a disaster that
is so unimaginable that it turns their
lives upside down
they are mourning the loss of their
loved one while also wondering how they
will pay the mortgage or put food on
their table
these are the very same families who
supported their loved one throughout the
many nights weekends holidays that they
worked away from home many times 24 to
48 hours straight
these are the very same families who
laid awake at night wondering if their
loved one would make it home from their
last shift
and these are the same the the very same
families who watched their loved one
grow distant and detached as they
silently fought their battle with
depression or ptsd
we owe it to these families to help
provide some level of dignity and relief
in their life
and while it won't bring their loved
ones back it will help to ensure their
families can begin to heal
the leaders of the professional
firefighters in new hampshire vow to
continue our fight to educate our
members to reduce the stigma surrounding
behavioral health and to do whatever we
can to help prevent any further loss of
life of this devastating illness
until such time that that we can win
this fight we ask the committee to
support senate bill 227.
i thank you for your time and i would be
happy to answer any questions
are there any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much i
appreciate it
thank you for your time
i now call on lynn cusack
good morning madam chair
good morning members of the committee my
name is lynne marie kuzak and i am an
attorney with the department of
corrections my job over there is the
director of professional standards
in that role
i
see the work that our corrections
officers do on a daily basis and the
struggles that many of them have with
depression stress and anxiety related to
the jobs that they hold
um
some of you have recently been on tours
of our facilities and have witnessed
firsthand what it
is like inside one of our facilities but
what you don't understand is that
day-to-day
role that our corrections officers and
our corrections line staff play in those
facilities where we have for example in
our men's facility
gang wars
we have
what we call the security threat groups
or gangs
that um try to bring contraband into the
facilities that contraband being drugs
and there's
wars over who is going to make the most
money off of selling those drugs and
those wars sometimes turn violent and
our corrections officers have to deal
with that those violent activities that
occur in the facility on a daily basis
one of the things that
that we see in the corrections field is
and studies have shown and the testimony
that i've just handed out to you has
links to some of the this testimony or
the studies that have been done
show that corrections officers have a
higher rate or higher incidence of
depression and anxiety and suicide than
that of the local law enforcement police
police officers one study shows that
that anxiety and stress or
post-traumatic stress syndrome
syndrome
is at about 53 percent of corrections
officers where it's 30 some percent for
police officers and suicides are six
percent higher than the average uh in
the general population
we don't see suicides occurring
in our
population our our staff population but
if it occurs and the anxiety and the
stress that occurs
if it happens we think that our
corrections officers
and our probation and parole officers
should have the same
advantage or their families have the
same advantage that other law
enforcement in the state of new
hampshire do have when it comes to
taking care of their families
as a result of a suicide that occurs
because of death in
or excuse me a suicide that occurs
because of the stress that occurs
resulting from the job
another interesting
point that i
would like to make and i've testified in
the senate on this
that there is an officer down memorial
page
that shows you on an annual basis the
number of
law enforcement that are killed in the
line of duty or take their own life
by suicide and the the numbers are sort
of striking
in that in 2015 167 individuals
nationwide in law enforcement were
killed in the line of duty six of those
were corrections officers and 50 of
those that were
killed were killed by assault
now
the bill not only for corrections
officers allows the the suicide to be
incorporated in the death benefit but it
for the first time allows corrections
officers to also be included in any
death benefit
and what we're also proposing is that we
include the probation and parole
officers who on a daily basis are out on
the streets
working with those felons that still
have sentences remaining
that same page that i was talking about
the officer down memorial page
uh shows that in 2017 there were 186
deaths in law enforcement nine of them
were
excuse me
this was 2017 186 deaths nine of them
corrections officers and about 50
percent of those were through or from a
heart attack
in 2018 188 deaths 12 corrections
officers and then in 1920 and 21 we see
those numbers increasing to about 400
deaths an average of about 400 deaths
per year but they were due mostly to
covet
so we're not seeing
the rates and numbers and again these
are nationwide numbers so from a fiscal
impact to the state of new hampshire we
at the department of corrections don't
see this as anything that is significant
and
would be a challenge to the state to pay
for any law enforcement including
corrections officers who die in the line
of duty or by suicide
if there are no questions i will take my
seat but i'm happy to answer any
questions
representative weiler
uh thank you
uh miss cusack did you bring this
proposal to the senate to have probation
parole officers included yes we did so
um the we started or initiated this
process in um 2020 i believe with house
bill or 2021 with house bill 91
and we attempted to change some language
there
in this year we brought
forward and included
not only our probation and parole
officers but corrections line personnel
so we attempted to change the definition
of who law enforcement were in that bill
unfortunately both of those bills were
laid on the table and sent to in
potentially interim study
this is our last chance for this
legislative session to get something
done for our corrections officers thank
you for the information thank you
representative yep representative emrick
thank you madam chair
so we need to have an amendment that
includes
probation officers parole officers are
there any other titles that need to be
included and what we would also our
legend or our testimony says corrections
line personnel and those individuals are
our nurses our social workers our
chaplains
who work in the facility and our subject
potentially to the same serious threats
that our corrections officers are
the federal
there's federal law that and the bureau
of prisons allows their corrections line
personnel to receive these benefits
including chaplains i've i've read
testimony and seen the legislation on
that
so the follow-up
yes the term corrections line personnel
would cover all these all the ancillary
they're a little bit different than the
probation and parole officer so it would
be corrections officers
probation parole officers and correction
line personnel which yes does include
those ancillary chaplains nurses social
workers thank you
are there any further questions
representative heath
thank you madam chair um my question is
just with regard to juvenile parole
officers
um where would they fit in this so the
department of corrections does not
we we do not have
any juvenile probation and parole
officers as our employees they are with
department of health and human services
and i am uncertain as to whether they um
have taken a
active
role in in looking at this legislation
thank you
represent walt
that was my first question that was
answered about jppos that i think if
you're going to include probation and
parole officers we should be including
jppos because there's really no
difference but i i just want to let you
know that about 10 years ago this body
created a study of gangs in this state
and i sat on that commission and the
finding was is that we didn't we had a
small problem with gangs in manchester
and nashua but the biggest problem with
gangs was within our prisons and it
sounds like that's unchanged is that
true
i am not um aware and don't have any
statistics about the number of gangs
that are in our population outside of
our prisons i am very familiar with the
gangs inside of our prisons and
are of about uh 1200 people that are in
our
con facility in concord
we have 300 and some odd
members of gangs or again security
threat groups that are have been
certified by our staff as being active
participants in a gang the largest gangs
that we have are the bloods um and the
um
latin kings i believe is another large
gang and then obviously the the home
grown security threat group of bao the
brothers of white warrior is also a
significantly sized uh security threat
group in our facilities so yes they
still exist
we do our best to fight that contraband
i have a staff of 14 internal affairs
investigators that not only do internal
affairs work about
employee misconduct or or that sort of
thing but also
are
actively pursuing and bring criminal
prosecutions against those individuals
that are
are actively bringing contraband and
assaulting
individuals in our facility
we're bringing those charges on a
monthly basis we've get indictments
are there any further questions
thank you very much appreciate your
testimony thank you madam chair
uh
mr j ward
thank you madam chair um actually i was
going to testify on the same exact stuff
that
miss cusack did so you don't have to
hear from me
okay thank you very much i appreciate uh
i appreciate that
um
i do have a question
is there anyone in the audience that
knows why
the
senate did not include
the parole probation and correction line
officers
in the bill
okay
uh representative
thank you madam chair um if it would be
possible could the uh
uh senator bursal
answer a couple technical questions on
the language
representative turcotte thank you madam
i assume you have a question
i do have i
understand can i just make a statement i
will find out uh what happened um with
the
amendment
in senate i think it's either edna or
senate finance i'm not sure
okay thank you very much
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the stand again um i understand
the general concept my questions i have
a couple on
uh
the tech the technical language i guess
would be the the uh
issue
is it the intent of this
that
any suicide of the named individuals
that are under here would automatically
uh
be eligible for the payout is that the
intent
my understanding is
there is first an investigation because
we we covered this in our commission
um
there's when there's a whenever there's
a death whether it's a suicide and you
can correct me if i'm wrong over there
but anytime there's a death whether
suicide or
a typical
line of duty
there is an investigation and if they
find that this was a cause
um was an in line of duty cause then it
would be eligible for payout
thank you follow up thank you um
okay
on line five it talks um
i think it kind of introduces a new a
new term let's go back actually line
four we it talks of an incident accident
violence cause of dance death and
injuries and then on line five and six
it introduces a term called work related
yet it's not really
defined as work related supposed to be
the same as an incident or is it
what what is that
it just appears to me to introduce
something new that's not really
delineated or defined
well i think going back to my first
answer is after the investigation if
it's um looked at as work related or
caused by
an incident that they had then it would
be work-related cause of death
that finding has to be
um that it has to have a finding of warp
related is my understanding
thank you one more one more thank you
so uh
on line six then it talks about the
incident
on
who will make the determination is so it
would that be your intent that
the determination is made by one of the
three or four indiv
groups or individuals that are listed
there
well again i think it's the workers comp
insurance carrier that would be doing
the investigation as well as the police
department or the fire department or the
corrections department
along with the insurance the workers
comp insurance carrier
would determine
okay thank you
hope that helps
represent lynn
thank you
uh senator just a quick question i so
should i understand that i think that
the issue that
may raise the question and this might be
part of what representative turcotte was
asking about is it talks in the on line
three about
um
uh
killed in the line of duty uh means
while in the performance of of your
duties so i but i take it from what
you're saying is for example
let's suppose that uh there's you know
i'm sort of making up a uh
an example that may it may not
may not in fact
uh
comport with with what actually happened
but suppose that there's like there's
been a series of tragic fires let's say
where
other firemen have been killed in the
in the line of duty that kind of thing
and a fireman
um
commits suicide not at the scene or on
the way to or or
or back to the station from the scene
but a few days later
am i understanding correctly from what
you've said that if if it were
determined by
you know the insurance company or
appropriate medical professionals that
in fact the cause of the of the firemen
suicide
several days later was as a result of
the series of incidents that had
happened where fellow officers had been
killed etc that would be eligible for
the benefit
that is my intention and as well as
we've we've heard testimony dur in the
commission often times where
uh firefighters or police officers have
gone to several fires let's say and
they've found they've had to deal with
the death of young children or babies
it doesn't happen right away it
sometimes it takes months
for this to um develop into a suicidal
attempt and there
many times there may be some
signs that the family sees but the
the their workers don't see
but many times it takes months
and develop um
the suicidal tendencies and so yes um it
doesn't happen right away it can take
weeks months even sometimes years
thank you
are there any further questions
represent murray
thank you madam chair i forgive my
naivete um i'm from a very small town
and we rely a lot on volunteers
and basically if something happens
everybody shows up and some of these
volunteers particularly emts and the
firefighters
this is what they do they're very
dedicated to this and in reading this
when i first read it i'm hearing that
it's for professionals
but the way i'm reading it now after
representative turcotte's comments does
this pertain to volunteers as well
it better
i will i will have to check on that but
i believe it does oh thank you but and
um
the chief also just
had me look at this um this is based on
a supreme court decision um
the dotier case it says there are four
types of injury-causing risks commonly
faced by an employee at work
one risks directly associated with
employment
two risks personal to the claimant
three mixed risks and four neutral risks
the first category employment related
risks includes the risk of injuries
generally recognized as industrial
injuries such as fingers being caught in
gears
this category of risk always arises out
of employment now the daughter decision
um was made not too long ago
20 november or 2020
that and the opinion was issued that
suicide can be seen as work-related
so
thank you very much uh represent walls
what court issued that decision
i'm sorry what court issued that
decision to state the federal
supreme court in new hampshire thank you
is there anything else
seeing none and thank you very much oh
i'm sorry uh rep
representative murray's uh question is
still
ponder i'm still pondering it and i
don't think we got a good answer
does anybody know what the definition of
professional is in terms of emts and
firefighters
uh would it just be for the fact that
they get paid many volunteer fire
members
pay their
colleagues when they respond
same with emts it's a de minimis amount
but nevertheless they're they're paid so
would that
automatically include them i'm not a
lawyer i don't know but i i would think
it would be a travesty if it did
i'm not confident but i will get back
i'm i've
i know this has been a topic of
conversation in the commission
um our intent was to i believe include
everyone whether um volunteer or
professional
if i may madam chair yes if we're making
an amendment i would
propose including language that would be
definitive and assure that they are
certainly included thank you madam chair
okay thank you
thank you senator senator bertsell for
coming back and
answering some of our questions i
i really appreciate it and i'll try and
get back to you on that other question
okay thank you very much
uh
i have no further
um pink cards so i'm closing the hearing
on sb 277.
sorry i closed the hearing on the wrong
bill two two
two two seven
okay
uh thank you
we did have um
adam schmidt
who did not testify
from the new hampshire association of
fire chiefs
and he is in favor of the bill
so thank you very much
yes
okay i'm i'm sorry it got
under
the other
bill
all right is there anything
anything you need to add i can it's no
big deal
okay all right
okay i'm sorry i missed the pink card so
we will reopen the hearing
on
sb 227
so that holly stevens
can provide some additional information
to us and please turn on your microphone
thank you
thank you chair umberger members of the
committee i'll make this very quick
i apologize for being a little bit late
to the hearing i had another meeting
going on
i just wanted to go on record holly
stevens the public policy director of
nami new hampshire that nami new
hampshire is in support of senate bill
227 as we were in support of house bill
91 which is a bill that's uh nearly
identical to this one
that passed um it was a bill from last
session that passed the house um
in the first session of this year um was
considered by the senate
and
they ended up i think uh voting at
interim study and moving the senate bill
to 27 forward
um
you know we know that
there are high numbers of suicides for
first responders
higher than the general public so we
know that this work has an effect on
those individuals
that does stem directly from the work
and that being said though there's not
an overabundance luckily of
these suicides in new hampshire i
believe there's been between five and
in the last um
six or seven years
um but to those families even though
there's not not very many of them to
those families this this death benefit
benefit would be tremendous
and that's why we're in support of it um
and i'll end it there again just make it
sweet and we're in support of it and
urge the committee to support this bill
thank you okay thank you very much are
there any questions
seeing none now can i close the hearing
thank you very much okay
i will now open the hearing on senate
bill
relative to disaster relief loans
uh senator prent
apprentice
welcome
good morning and uh madam chair members
of the house finance committee for the
record my name is
suzanne prentice and i'm the state
senator for district five which covers
nine communities along the connecticut
river valley and i'm honored and pleased
to be here this morning to introduce to
you senate bill
409 um this bill
amends rsa 21p 37-c
section c to further clarify how
communities can obtain an emergency loan
from the state for recovery for a
catastrophic natural disaster
i'm going to
summarize
a story from this summer and i i trust
that representative aaron is going to
talk about this as well but i categorize
this bill as being a bill that's you
know for for the little guys helping out
the smaller communities and i think
that's an important perspective to keep
as we move forward
in the summer of 2021 parts of cheshire
and sullivan county were impacted by two
storms causing damage to roadways key
pathways to work
school and sustainability
sustainability of the local economic to
school and sustainability of the local
economy
these communities include but on our
limited to charlestown which is in
district 5
and ackworth which is in district 8.
there's three to four inches of rain
that fell over acworth on the night of
july 29th and 30th washed out roads
roads damaged bridges and destroyed
culverts around 30 roads which is three
quarters of the town's total so i'm
talking about acworth here and again
representative aaron can correct me if
i'm wrong we're damaged according to the
engineer hired to oversee the repairs
over a period of months necessary
repairs have waited and some still do
due to the part in lack of local dollars
to address the need while waiting for
federal help to arrive
in acworth a town
of under 900 residents and with a budget
shy of three million dollars repairs
were estimated at more than a million
dollars the amount the estimate provided
exceeded to the towns exceeded the
town's immediate ability to address the
situation in open roads in a separate
community in charlestown school children
traveled over and continued to travel
over
what's close to a class six road due to
a delay in necessary repairs it struck
me that if we could move funding to
these communities more expediently in
the form of a non-interest bearing loan
a no interest loan we would
be able to address the safety and
economic issues presented while the f
federal disaster relief process is
underway
although work has to be done to address
this through the all the work has been
done to address this through the
exceptional disaster relief loans i'm
asking to just add this one more option
and adding this this one more option
creates the ability and as the law is
amended for the governor to declare a
natural disaster and then go to governor
and council and approve requests and
government council would ultimately
approve an immediate
non-interest-bearing loan for that
community
uh and so fema disaster relief can often
take years to be received a temporary
emergency loan is particularly helpful
when a disaster would financially
overwhelm a community and require a
large appropriation that's raised from
local taxes
so two more things i just want to point
out in this is that in the senate we
amended this original bill so you're
seeing what's amended and in that
amendment what we did was we clarified i
originally had
joint fiscal in here
but we took joint fiscal out and went
with the governor's request to governor
and council to make this approval the
second was that a community cannot
request more than what their estimates
with what the final request is going to
be to fema
and that they are responsible in
municipality to pay the loan
back to the state and if there is
less received back
to that community than what the loan was
for
then they will work with governor and
council and the governor's office to
negotiate the terms of the payback
to to the state of new hampshire
it's been my experience i know we have
folks from homeland security and
emergency management here that can touch
on this that the s the process that's
done on estimates
is done very well so what i'm hoping is
not to put in a community ever in a
position where they've borrowed more
than
they really need but if they do there
would be a mechanism again to negotiate
those terms
and as i wrap up here again i just want
to share with you i you know i although
i live in west lebanon new hampshire now
i spent high representative mary nice to
see you i spent a number of years living
in the north country
and have you know lived in smaller
communities and have seen what can
happen when a natural disaster
overwhelms them and i want to compare
that to my experience living in the city
of lebanon and being a city councilor
there when we had a micro burst that
wiped out an entire road
side basically an entire part of the
neighborhood had no connection to the
main part of our city and it was a
multi-million dollar um as you know
repairs that needed to be made and it
was a huge safety issue we have um it
doesn't make us better or smarter but we
had more money set aside in
you know in our rainy day fund pardon
the pun we had a larger population and
we were able to take from our own
coffers to make the immediate repairs so
that people could actually drive up and
down their roads and be safe and have
water at their houses while we went
through the fema process
so that and when fema paid us back you
know we paid our you know we paid
ourselves back smaller communities are
not always in this position and i just
think it's important that we recognize
that and try to provide a mechanism for
them
to really help themselves and their
residents be safe support their
businesses their school children and so
on during these really tough times i'm
happy to answer any questions you have
and if i don't have the answer i'll
certainly get back to you and thank you
for your time this morning
thank you senator prentice are there any
questions
representative heath
thank you
madam chairman thank you senator
prentice it's so nice to see you here my
question
is with regard to
governor and council um within this bill
if and when i listened to what happened
to at birth it was just so
horrible and they needed immediate help
right away um and governor council only
meets every two weeks
will with this bill give authority to
the governor in council to poll them
remotely
to get permission to begin the process
almost immediately or do they have to go
through the every two weeks
thank you for the question
representative heath and it's good to
see you today as well
it would not allow for any
polling
immediately i'm sure that as is with
news like this it does travel fast and
counselors
are prepared you know to address the
issue and i think the good news about
governor council is that they do meet
twice a month
and which is
again puts us on a faster track than
where we currently are today so i hope
that addresses your question
representative leitchman
thanks madam chair uh thanks for
appearing how are you good how are you
so i'd like to take it a little further
as far as your no interest loans and
trying to protect the smaller
communities
was there consideration of just grants
within your legislation so these small
communities like acworth would not be
responsible for paying back these
so-called loans even though they're
interest-free as you've said but
wouldn't it be more
they were just strictly grants
the um manager and representatives
thank you for the question so keep in
mind that they're going to borrow this
money from the state and then they're
going to get reimbursed by fema so
they're going to get that money back and
then they need to pay the state back
so that is the structure of it the only
time we could get into muddy water is if
the
for some reason they got less from fema
than what they have borrowed and it
provides again language in here so there
could be a negotiation
okay so they so they're not it's not a
loan that they don't you know they're
going to get money from they will get
money from fema to pay back the loan
thanks thanks venom chair you're welcome
representative mooney
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for being here thank you i last night
pulled house bill 1665
which came to this committee recently
establishing a municipal road and bridge
disaster relief fund i see the prime
sponsor in the audience i'm just curious
uh if perhaps you or maybe she could
answer if there could be a marriage
between your bill and this bill
thank you for the question
representative mooney is this uh
representative aaronsville i'm always um
happy to work with representative aaron
we both have um
if you're if you're comfortable a common
goal in solving this problem so if
that's what we need to do then that's
what we need to do and i'm happy to work
with representative aaron okay thank you
representative lynn
yes thank you and i'm sure thanks for
taking my question uh i just wanna with
regard to subsection d
about about negotiation in other words
if the
if the amount of the fema
uh money is less than the amount of the
no interest loan
it says
shall negotiate repayment terms of the
difference do i should i understand
the
that language to mean
that there is an obligation to repay
there's no question that the that the
municipality has to repay the loan the
only question for negotiation is
for example over what period of time
what interest right rate might apply
or is it
that
maybe they don't have to repay the loan
or they don't have to repay all of it
and that's supposed to be the subject of
negotiation
representative lin thank you for the
question so i think the way that i read
this and in my thinking is that
negotiation
includes the potential for a forgiveness
depending on the size again i'd like to
think that our size of the amount i like
to think that our estimates based on my
experience that come from fema and what
is actually you know is going to be
borrowed here
should be should be down to the penny
but if
i would leave that to governor and
council to make that decision on what
negotiation is because they're
ultimately going to do it
right follow-up
follow-up so i guess my own
please understand i'm completely
supportive of this bill but but i i
guess what i'm wondering is
you know when you say they will
negotiate okay they'll negotiate suppose
they don't come to a decision and it
goes to court because they can't agree
what does the court do what's the law
they have to negotiate what is that what
does that mean they've negotiated they
haven't been able to come to an
agreement what does the
what what's the law in terms of whether
the court
you know record what what does the court
say well you do have to pay it all back
or you don't or
that's that's the thing that i see as
sort of a problem i understand and
you're i represent when you're certainly
uh you know have outpaced me and
experience on the judicial side as i'm
i'm aware but i um
i'd have to think about that i mean if
this went to
a court if if the law says it's a
negotiation and again i don't have the
judicial experience you are between
governor council and that community they
could ultimately turn around and push
the decision back to governor council in
the community to make that decision or
they could rule i can't say what a what
a court may or may not do but i think
that you're i understand your concern i
want to be clear thank you you're
welcome representative wyler
i'm also
uh shocked by this
pay it all back because
the way it generally works is you know
it comes years later but
fema will pay like 75
and then the town or the state
will split up the other 25
sometimes to the advantage of the town
sometimes not sometimes they expect to
split that 25
so
i've seen cases where the state takes a
bigger share than the town
that could still apply but that's might
be the negotiation in this situation
thank you
thank you representative weiler i know
it's not a question but i do want to
again
just point out that we do have homeland
security and emergency management in the
room and they'll speak to
there's a process for this that's
already in place in terms of
the applications and how the the paying
back and the percentage goes so
we'd be sure if you have questions we
can address that with home and security
and emergency management thank you
representative petry
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um
have you checked into uh similar things
like tan notes
text tax anticipation notes
because it seems so we could apply the
same
process
you know in other words we we do it at
the county all the time we borrow money
to to survive the
you know because we don't get funded
uh into the budget process
so have you checked into that at all
because tech it would seem to solve the
problem because you you're anticipating
money from fema
possibly the state
and then
the rest of the share of the of the
municipality
thank you um representative petrie no i
um frankly i have not looked into tax
anticipation notes but i would be happy
to do that i mean you know i brought my
laptop if i may follow up if it's not
you know it's tax anticipation but it
could follow the same logic
okay
are there any further questions
representative thank you madam chair
thank you senator um
this may be a better question for the
fema people later but on line seven when
it talks about the anticipated assistant
my concern is we have a floor
outlined in
lines nine through 11
on on the amount 25 of the amount raised
by local property taxes blah blah blah
my concern is the the top end of that
what that loan might be
and that kind of brings us back to i
think line seven where it talks about
anticipated assistance and my question
is how is that anticipated assistance
determined
so i
thank you for the question
representative turcotte i'm going to
defer a majority of this to our
to our state agency but i think the the
fema estimation process that they go
through
to make a determination about the damage
that's been done will
align with the anticipation but let's
hold and clarify there and thank you
great thank you uh i do have one oh
sorry i'll rip some irf
thank you thank you madam chair and
senator
is there significance to the change of
the word occurrence to incident
on lines nine and ten
that was an amendment that was made in
the finance committee of the senate um
and they just wanted to make sure um
that it was it was more all-encompassing
in case there were multiple occurrences
they preferred that language
so an occurrence is not an incident or
vice versa
so there could be an incident and there
could be multiple occurrences within an
incident
from different parts of a community so
that um same community
different problems so that um and you
know that's the policy statement i don't
disagree with it i was happy to take
make the amendment
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you everybody
have a great day
next person will call on representative
aaron
thank you mr chair thank you committee
for hearing me today for the record my
name is representative judy aaron
i represent sullivan county district
seven which is acworth goshen langdon
leemster and washington
and i come to you today in support of
this
senate bill
i believe that it
certainly makes some
positive marginal change to current
statute
living in acworth
and having to deal with the
massive damage that happened to our town
this past july 29th
i have to tell you that current statute
really
was useless for us
we were in desperate need of immediate
help
and the statute currently didn't do
anything for us
because
it wasn't until maybe three or four
months after the event happened
that there was a presidential
declaration of emergency
and
of course when
a horrific event like this happens to
your town
you can't wait three or four months to
reopen roads and get people to their
homes and
be able to get emergency vehicles
through
you can't even
do a proper rfp
to have you know things go out to bid
you have to grab whoever is available
to get roads fixed and passable and safe
to be able to get to utility poles
that are damaged to be able to
have farmers be able to get to their
fields
we were in a situation where all hands
were on deck
you couldn't wait
for the state you couldn't wait for the
federal government
and that was the position that we were
in
and i have to say
even with the prospect
of
having
being able to get a loan from the state
that was not an option for us at the
time because there was no guarantee we
were told
that oh you can apply for for a loan
from the state and this was after the
emergency declaration
became available
but that process would take maybe three
to six months and we don't know whether
you know
whether you apply for it you're going to
get granted the money
so with no assurances at all
the only thing that acworth
had as an option at the time
once we were scrambling around trying to
get everything reopened
was to go to a local bank muscoma bank
and we got a 2.1 million dollar loan
yeah we could have come to the state
but we had no assurance at all whether
what we asked for
would come to any kind of
reality and the reality is when you need
the money you need the money
so
i know that senator daniels had asked me
recently well why didn't you get a loan
from the state well this was why because
we were told
you'd have to
work on all this paperwork to get and
whatever bureaucracy
to request a loan from the state and
there's no assurance at the end of that
whether you would get it there's no
assurance that we'll get anything
from the
projects that we've submitted to fema
i mean we've got several projects in the
pipeline now
and we have no assurance that any of
those are going to be compensated from
fema
none
but the reality is you got to get the
work done
so we said we get the work done we
submit it and
cross our fingers and hope for the best
and i gotta say too i've gotten letters
from several other
um
several other select board members in my
district one from leemster
leemster is in a precarious situation
where we've spent one point
uh one and a quarter million dollars of
our own money to partially rep partially
partially repair roads and bridges from
the flood last summer
we had
have not had to borrow money nor did we
ask for any at town meeting
but we're certainly close to running out
of funds because of this
we've paid every bill that's come across
our desk in regard to this problem and
don't see any monies coming from fema in
the near future in fact in acworth we're
not expecting any kind of fema payments
until maybe
summer at this point
currently
[Music]
these towns are waiting and waiting for
funds to come through
i had another letter from
lucian beam who is a select board member
of langdon
and he wrote to me to tell me that
because of route 12 being closed down in
charlestown
because you know route 12 is falling
into the connecticut river slowly
it's having an impact on two roads in
langdon
hemlock south hemlock road and mini road
were subject to heavy vehicle counts
they went from a traffic count of 50
cars a day to well over a thousand
and that includes trucks and that
includes school buses
so
clearly you know with that kind of uh
of
traffic
with this responsibility for langdon
comes the cost of maintaining those two
roads which to date has cost the town 28
thousand dollars in the form of gravel
stone stone sand salt and labor
and
there's no guarantee fema is going to
cover any of that
so these towns in this area it's not
just acworth aquathea we got we got hit
pretty badly but the surrounding towns
have gotten badly hurt as well
and the fact of the matter is
these towns are suffering financially we
don't have the tax base to be able to
uh you know have s have a big pot of
money saved
to to deal with these kinds of disasters
and we had hoped that that the state
would come through and you know toss us
a bone something
do something to help us
but
all i can say is
this particular
statute
and the changes
is an improvement
but i don't know that it goes far enough
to really help us in the immediate
uh time when when an event like this
happens
and of course as we are going forward
we have ongoing expenses
and we're just sitting and waiting for
fema reimbursement if that ever comes so
that's kind of all i wanted to report to
you and
i hope that as a committee you can do
something
to
maybe improve this to to be able to give
more immediate funding to these towns
either
right after the event happens or as they
are sitting and waiting and waiting for
any kind of reimbursement from the
federal government it would be nice if
the state could just grant some money
and yes i know you know to
representative leishman's question
i know that
there's an expectation well you're going
to be getting money from the federal
government well you know it would be
nice not to have to
rely on them to begin with
and
that's all i have to say i'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you very much
representative aaron uh president weiler
thank you madam chair thank you
representative aaron
keep careful track of all the money the
town spends
that will be like a soft match if they
ever demand any kind of match all that
can be considered so
if as long as somebody's keeping track
of all that extra work
it's going to be credited you may not be
repaid for it in full
but at least
that's a beginning thank you
are there any further
questions represent leishman
thanks man of chair thanks for your
testimony and appearing so i do have a
concern as you indicated and picked up
on as far as these small towns coming up
with any sort of repayment because you
have such a limited tax base but i'm
curious the 2.1 million dollar loan what
were the terms for repayment do you
recall
the bank mascoma bank bless their hearts
are
are working with us
they have been very very generous in
their terms
they are willing to work with us they
realize the
enormous impact this has had on a town
our size were 850 people
we have an annual operating budget of
1.3 million dollars
the damage that was done in our town
has been estimated upwards of 26 million
and 26 million uh you know certainly
that would be if every road was put back
perfectly the way it's supposed to with
the right size culverts with the right
size everything it's you know the
perfect the way it should be we're
probably not going to get to that
because as whatever we can budget is
what
whatever we can pay is what we're going
to be able to pay and
so we may not be able to use the biggest
rightist kind of culvert for any
particular road
but we'll do what we can do within our
financial means
and right now we're sitting here
thinking okay well we're sort of with
this 2.1 million dollar loan we've
structured it to be sort of like a home
equity loan that you can tap into
grab some money to do a project
when you get reimbursed from the project
you take some of that funding and you
put it back pay back that
part of the loan so we're only being
we're only having to pay interest on the
amount of that money that we've been
pulling out not the whole 2.1 million
so
the bank has been very generous in their
terms in working with us to do that
and um
so we're
you know
we spent i think
last year
i think we spent about 1.3 million on
road repair and we are estimating for
this year 1.6 million
and
some of that is going to be loan money
some of that is tax money and
you know we'd be
we'd be blessed if the state threw us
some extra money to help us in the form
of a grant but i don't see that that's
gonna happen
unfortunately you never know i please i
would love it if you can do that
are there any further questions uh
representative
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
your testimony it certainly underscores
the need for this
legislation uh my question is i had one
that representative leishman had asked
but the second one that i was thinking
about was have you reached out to our
congressional
delegation
and were they able to apparently not
able to help pressure fema no we
contacted just about everybody that we
could and uh there was nothing that they
could seem to do for us
are there further questions
thank you very much representative aaron
and appreciate it
i will now call on um
catherine heck
good morning representative umberger and
members of the committee
morning
my name is catherine heck and i
represent the new hampshire municipal
association and we are here to support
senate bill 409 and i won't reiterate
all the reasons what were stated in
previous testimony except to say that
always additional financial tools in the
event of an emergency or disaster can be
beneficial to our communities
to representative mooney's point we have
senate bill 402 that's
going to be coming over to the house
that creates an avenue for the governor
to approve
with the executive council
and disburse financial assistance to
municipalities as well as
rsa 13 colon 4 already allows the
governor to
grant such emergency grants in the event
of an emergency through specific
channels so that combined with fema and
legislation like this that could
hopefully fill some of the gaps that
exist in the event of a catastrophic
municipal emergency so i will keep my
testimony short and answer any questions
you might have
thank you very much are there any
questions
seeing none
i will now thank you very much for your
testimony i will call on jennifer
harper
good morning thank you very much for
having us my name is jennifer harper i'm
the director for homeland security and
emergency management
and with me is fallon reed who is our
special projects uh coordinator and who
has been dealing with our disaster
recovery process for about the last six
years
so she's really the expert so
the bill as amended
we do
concur with it
we were involved in the edits of it the
amendments of it
there is an exceptional disaster relief
loan rule
um that will be amended
based on the outcome of what happens
with this bill
but i just want fallon to go through a
couple of the points that may answer
some questions that have come up in this
sure excuse me just a minute
um
you said there's another bill out there
this bill came from the current 21p 37
see so
there's the we already have
administrative rules to reflect the
current
um
bill that senator guida put through in
so there's
rules that will answer some of the
questions you all brought up
that would just be amended based on the
outcome of this
okay
and and we do need a card from you as
well sure okay so sword interrupt please
go ahead no that's okay um so a couple
notes i just based on previous questions
that um you had asked
so in regards to um
the house bill 1665 the one that
representative aaron sponsored for the
roads and bridges so one thing that had
come up with that
and goes to
the conversation between a loan and a
grant
is if the state were to grant a
community money for these repairs it
would conflict with fema eligibility and
so fema would not be able to reimburse
the communities because they would
consider it
duplication of benefits so
through
21p37 and other things the state has
loaned has come up with this loan which
is just a temporary to get them through
which fema does not see as a duplication
of benefits it's just a temporary loan
of money so that's kind of the
difference between
some of those things
as i mentioned we do have rules already
so there is a
piece in the rule
about the loan repo repayment
that if the amount that the fema
assistance is
the state treasurer
with the advice and consent of governor
and council shall negotiate the terms of
repayment
if the local and state treasurer are
unable to reach an agreement the
department of revenue administration
shall include the amount in the amount a
portion of setting property tax rates so
i'm hoping that answers your question
representative
lynn about um what to do if we can't
come to an agreement
um
as far as how the anticipated assistance
is determined there's a couple steps in
that so when we have a disaster that
occurs in the state
and our office the division of homeland
security and emergency management which
is a division within safety will reach
out to our local and state partners to
assess what their initial damage
assessments are and if we think we're
going to meet the threshold which is
just over two million dollars then we'll
have fema come in and validate those
costs with us to do a preliminary damage
assessment which is what we did um after
the storms this
summer and so the damage assessments for
both those storms
together was just about six million
dollars but that's not all-inclusive
they get to a point where they're
comfortable saying yes you have exceeded
it and then that triggers the request
from us to
the president for the disaster
declaration and what's been going on now
and since october when we received the
disaster declaration
is the more detailed
line item assessment of the actual cost
which as of last week um
is not completely validated but between
the two disasters were right around the
18 million mark so you can see where we
started at you know the 6 million with
what fema initially said and we're up to
18 and we're working on validating all
of those
as far as the current loan goes
for exceptional disaster relief it's a
one-page loan application
and just a few pieces of information
that are needed from the community
we work off of the damage assessment
numbers um to do the loan we have yet to
issue a loan under this program yet um
we haven't had a request for that
but it is a we would fast track that as
it's needed that the information or the
money is needed
um it's currently at
with the interest rate that's listed in
the current rules says no greater than
the prevailing rate
and then with this modification to zero
interest we think that would be
beneficial to everyone
um
one other piece that i did want to
mention represent wyler with the public
assistance program there is no soft
match so
it's for our non-disaster grants that
have a soft match the disaster grants on
the community or the applicant is
responsible for the 25
unless we come up with something else
currently for these two disasters based
on
some um items that the president has
passed it's a 9010 split right now so
the applicant's only responsible for 10
for these two disasters
um
and that's kind of i'm hoping i answered
all the questions you had previously and
we're certainly willing to answer
anything else that may come up
representative weiler
no by soft match you say the community
might be responsible for 10 percent
wouldn't that include all the work
they've done so the um
the work that they have done
is what is reimbursed at you know 75 or
90 in this case
they are not responsible to
pay us the 10 or anything like that they
would just
um either absorb that or if the state
were to make a modification which is
what the senate bill 402 is looking to
do is have that opportunity based on the
amendment that
was passed through last week for the
governor to
be able to say you know we'd like to
help the community and it's kind of
open-ended so that it's not a
we the bill had originally started with
um 12 and a half 12 and a half
but basically it was amended so that a
community could ask the governor to go
to
the legislature and say we'd like to
help them
for whatever amount is deemed but so
soft match generally when it comes to
the grants is
we look at volunteer time or staff time
and offset that it doesn't apply for
disaster grants because you're looking
more at the labor materials all that
kind of stuff so it's a it's a cash kind
of responsibility so fema will cover 75
or 90
and then it's on the individual
applicant to make sure that they cover
the 10 or whatever percent it happens to
be for that disaster thank you
representative lynn
thank you madam chair so
i just want to make sure that i'm going
to if i'm understanding what you said
that there's a rule that has been
adopted by dra is it that so it's a dos
the department of safety rule okay and
the
language in the rule
um
it's under the section for loan terms
paragraph b as in baker
and it says if the local government and
the state treasurer are unable to reach
an agreement on the repayment then dra
will include the amount
um in the amount of portions in setting
the property tax rate so so if if i'm
understanding the the bottom line of
that rule so to speak is if the if the
town and the state are not able to to
reach an agreement dra will say the town
loses
yes based on the way this paragraph is
okay and then and and may i just ask one
follow-up
you may and so then so now it's gonna
that money that has to be repaid is
gonna be included in the towns what the
town has to collect in taxes and then
will then be repaid to the state okay
thank you sure
are there any further questions
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair thank you for the question
excellent job going over everything that
was discussed one final question on line
seven with the anticipated assistance
you you gave a great
uh
description of how that occurs my my
question is
what is the anticipated timeline from
disaster to the time you determine what
that is
anticipated assistance from fema is
going to be
sure so i wish i had an easy answer for
you
in part of the situation we're in is a
state government administering a federal
program so we have to adapt to the
federal rules for the program
so um depending on the nature of the
disaster
can really determine how quickly
something can be processed so in
i believe it's 2018 for example march
2018 we had two disasters back to back
on the seacoast
one was a snow disaster where we had
exceptional amounts of snow
and emergency work was covered we were
able to get that disaster declaration
pay out the communities and close out in
a two-year span however we have other
large natural scale disasters like
flooding and things
that take years we just are closing out
hurricane irene
for nine years of work with that because
of the severity of it so what we're
looking to do right now there's two
categories of work essentially
with the fema program we have emergency
work which are things that are done
immediately following the disaster to
get to a livable status not perfect and
we have our permanent work is where we
look at mitigation so the priority right
now is getting through our emergency
work category so we can get some money
to the communities and i know that our
staff that's the priority is the
emergency work
um things
so
as representative erin said they likely
won't see any money until this summer
which is a true statement
and then the permanent work will come
after that as we meet milestones with
the projects
so it is a lengthy process with fema
which is why we were hopeful with this
loan with senator guida's work in the
previous years that this would be an
interim solution so that
smaller communities you know could
basically still put food on the table
and pay their staff but deal with the
disasters
so i don't have a hard and fast timeline
for you but it is a lengthy process as
is most federal programs unfortunately
follow-up yes thank you madam chair so
is it
fair to say that at a minimum for the
emergency portion of the
project you're looking at nine months to
a year at the minimum okay thank you
representative leitchman
thanks madam chair i guess i just
couldn't sit here any
longer after listening to the
representative from acworth and her
testimony and when you said there's a
rule
that says the dra will assign whatever
is not paid back in a follow-up to
representative lynn's question how fair
is that that a community has been
walloped with the 26 million dollars in
damage
they have an operating budget of one 1.3
million and then say they take out this
loan or another community and they can't
come to an agreement with the government
the state government and then the dra
assesses that on the taxpayers
um
sure if i may clarify so they would only
we would work with the community to do a
loan amount that is reasonable to their
damages
so um
you know if they had three million
dollars in damages or roughly around
there we wouldn't
encourage them to do a loan for 10
million so the repayment really comes
back to
if for some reason the fema eligibility
is less than what they took the loan for
but we would work with the community to
make sure that the loan amount they're
requesting is in line with what we
believe is eligible or likely to be
eligible
so the likelihood that it would need to
go
to the point where dra would um assign
tasks
i feel would be rare and with the
addition of the language
in this current amendment where it says
the municipality shall not knowingly
request a loan for more than what their
fema eligibility is that'll help kind of
put some guard rails so
let's say for example that
um backworth were to ask the state for
the 2.1 million dollar loan versus the
bank that is based on the amount of
damages they have completely reasonable
and i would expect that fema will
reimburse that two million if not much
more
so we only would get into the issue
where dra would need to tax the town or
the residents as if for some reason the
fema amount was much less than
um what we had originally given them the
loan for because what basically right
now we have what we think is eligible
and i can make a
educated decision on that but sometimes
there are things that
come in that are not eligible for
whatever reason we're not done
in line with codes and standards or
proper procurement or any of those kind
of administrative pieces but
i don't think we would knowingly or
willingly
com you know encourage the community to
do a loan that would be far in excess of
what fema would look at eligible
thanks sure thanks madam chair
are there any further questions uh
represent lin yes justin sort of follow
up to to that i wonder i mean
suppose that we that that we were
disposed to
to change the language of that last
section just a little bit and what i'm
thinking is suppose instead of saying
shall negotiate repayment of the terms
we said shall attempt to re
uh to negotiate repayment of the terms
and then added the following and if the
state and the municipality are unable to
reach agreement either party may seek
resolution of the matter by the superior
court which shall decide upon a
resolution that is fair and just under
all the circumstances would that
solve the i mean that would allow the
court then to decide
you know who should who should win or
whether it's appropriate to split the
matter somehow that yeah and based on
just
listening to that i don't see any
conflict with any of our federal
guidance or anything like that so i
think it would be worth pursuing to see
if that language would
meet what you're looking to do thank you
sure
um i do i anybody else
represent walls
thank you i'm just having a hard time
understanding the difference between the
18 million that you've approved in the
24 or 26 million that aggress said that
they have out there is it that they
thought that they needed to do things
and you didn't think that it fed within
federal guidelines sure so um and
certainly representative can clarify but
what she had mentioned was
their engineer had looked at essentially
soup to nuts fixing it and making it
better to prevent which includes
mitigation and right now our 18 million
dollars is only the immediate repairs to
get it back to the day before the next
step is to look at mitigation to improve
it so it doesn't happen again and we
just haven't gotten there that's not the
priority right now it's looking at what
is the immediate fix and then our goal
is through that process to have
mitigation so that things don't
happen again um if i make a quick
example so in the alstead floods back in
a similar type of disaster wiped the
community off the map but through the
public assistance program we were able
to do mitigation and these storms that
came through
those roads and bridges that had
mitigation weren't touched and it was
the perfect example of the mitigation
program
to show that we invested that money in
time to make things better to improve
and then they
made it out very well in these last
storms
follow-up yeah
so
in time acworth may see some of that
money either through this program or
another program but it's going to be
mitigation money not repair money it's
just a question of what silo it's in and
when it comes exactly
thank you
okay is there any any other questions
i do have one
and uh
maybe
when we go to our work session is when
we can answer it but everybody's talking
about small towns
but there's nothing in this legislation
that
is anything about a small town
it would appear to me
that
any town no matter whether you're small
or large
could apply for this
so
which is it are we trying to address
the small towns or are we trying to
address the entire state
i mean i don't know the answer to that
and i'm sure you don't either
um i mean
that's something
that
maybe division two can
think about a little bit but um
you know they're they're too you know
two different things here
representative amber one item that is in
here is the 25 of the town's operating
budget which i think for a larger
community or city would be an
exceptional amount of money which would
deem them ineligible for this so that
may clarify
the piece for it that this is intended
for small communities without coming out
and saying that
um but it is
that um in paragraph b
the
incident cost of the projects has to
equal or exceed 25 of the amount raised
by
taxes in the current budget so
i would presume that that would exclude
many of the larger
communities unless they were completely
you know devastated but
i'm not sure if that helps okay so all
right thank you sir
are there any other questions
all right seeing none
the hearing is closed
and i believe both division 1
and division 2
have work sessions
so if our division two friends could
join us
over there we'll take about five minutes
to stretch and um
oh okay
all right i just recessed till after the
hearing so okay
you could get the difference between
doing repair work and doing a
remediation
and you're doing it if you're working
you want to do the remediation
and fema doesn't want you to
remove them
now
thank you
okay
we'll call the uh
public hearing to order
we will be discussing
sb 371
making an appropriation to the lead
paint hazard remediation fund
and i see that
senator rosenwald is here
whoops that's the wrong one
okay
to
introduce the bill
i am welcome thank you madam chair good
afternoon committee members for the
record i'm cindy rosenwald i represent
senate district 13 which is most of
nashua
and i'm pleased to introduce senate bill
this bill will appropriate 3 million
dollars of general funds
in fiscal year 2023
to replenish the lead paint hazards
remediation fund
that is managed by the new hampshire
housing finance authority
this fund was established three years
ago
to offer zero interest loans to help
property owners
make housing safe for children
by remediating lead paint
child care centers
are also able to access this loan money
to remove lead hazards from drinking
water
and as this committee knows and i know
it's not the policy committee but
children exposed to lead dust from old
paint can suffer permanent brain damage
there is no safe level of lead and new
hampshire has some of the oldest
housing stock around and it's really all
over the state
we have
close to 500 children in the state who
have
been identified as having elevated blood
lead levels
um
and that
the
we've seen that in the three years since
we've established this
loan fund
about 300 units of housing
have been rehabbed
and the fund is now just about depleted
but we still have hundreds of children
who are at risk of irreparable name
brain damage
and i should note that the zero interest
loans from this fund are repaid when the
property is transferred so
it could be quickly could be a long time
but the money does come back
i did have um when i was filing this
ballotic conversation
with
hud
to see if the lead in drinking water
funds that are in the infrastructure
investment act could be used instead of
general funds
unfortunately that provision those funds
are to replace water service lines so
the the pipes out
on the street
not in individual private housing
and um
this bill came out of senate finance
unanimously it passed the senate on a
voice vote i hope this committee will
agree
that we
have more work to do to keep children
from being poisoned by lead
and um and then drinking water and i'm
happy to try and answer questions there
are subject matter experts
here though
thank you madam chair
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you senator roosevelt
and i i still have a hard time with the
senator rosenwald oh whatever
[Laughter]
knew you knew you too many years
otherwise
but i'm glad you're glad you're sitting
over in the senate
so uh
mr frost ben frost from
new hampshire housing
thank you madam chair and good afternoon
committee members my name is ben frost
i'm the deputy director of new hampshire
housing
and i'm
here
happily in support of senate bill 371
and with gratitude to senator rosenwald
for
uh
being the prime sponsor on this and
being here today to introduce
the bill um
we welcome the appropriation uh the
additional appropriation to the lead
fund which new hampshire housing
administers
the light fund was created as part of
the trailer bill in the 2019 biennial
budget
and was made part of new hampshire
housing's statute which is rsa 204c
so it is
it's a statutory fund it is a
non-lapsing fund so once once the
appropriation any appropriation is made
by the legislature to the fund it
becomes
essentially no longer state funds but
funds that are administered by new
hampshire housing on behalf of the state
and we
we spend it as as projects are presented
to us
as senator rosenwald said
something on the order of 300 units
using the initial 2019 appropriation of
3 million dollars have been remediated
of
the lead hazard
and that is mostly rental units although
we can also use it for
low-income single-family
owner-occupied residences but most of it
is for rental properties and these tend
to be
a smaller rental property so
mom and pop owners if you will
and that is the the vast bulk of where
this uh these this funding goes so these
are these are landlords who don't really
have a lot of capital uh available to
them to do this very expensive work
and so
we're there they're owning these
properties
and renting to low income tenants they
don't know the owners don't have the
financial wherewithal to perform the
remediation of lead paint hazards on the
property
this program
is a critical resource to helping to
ensure
the safety of children living in those
apartments and also in the single family
homes
this money was the the original fund as
i said was created in in 2019 with a
three million dollar appropriation by
the legislature as part of the uh the
trailer bill
um
to date uh
we have uh allocated almost all of those
three million dollars in fact we as of
today we have
um un uh unobligated
420 dollars
that's it
so it's all gone to the projects
that are in need of lead paint
remediation
when when i spoke
in support of this legislation in the
senate finance committee in the hearing
i was asked a question about
the repayment of the loans because these
are only done as loans then and that's
um that's by statutory uh requirement we
can't do grants
uh we would do loans anyway um
but
i was asked well how how long before
this becomes a self-sustaining fund
i will say it will be a long time before
this is a self-sustaining fund
in the past couple years we've been
running this program three loans have
been repaid for a total of fifty four
thousand dollars
and change so that's really not uh much
to keep a program running uh as senator
rosenwald said the loans are repaid at
the time a property is sold given that
landlords tend to hang on to their
properties because they are income
properties for them these properties
don't sell
in it on any regular basis they will
eventually and so those loans will come
back to the fund at some point
but
right now there is extraordinary demand
and extraordinary need for
the additional work to be done in those
properties all over the state
where we have lead paint hazards and it
is all over the state as senator
rosenwald said
we have one of the oldest housing stocks
in in the country that's just the nature
of
where we are and who we are
as a state
and that means that we have a
particularly high incidence of lead
paint in existing in these these rental
properties
lead paint was
banned by federal law in 1978 and we
have an awful lot of pre-1978 structures
currently occupied
all over the state
i will say that
just to give a
a
a hard number to it
we have completed
uh 286
housing units in the state using the
state funds that were
appropriated a couple years ago and
there's another seven that are still uh
underway so this is a little under 300
units that will have been remediated of
lead hazards
with the original three million dollars
that was made
so i'm happy to take any questions
before i do that i do want to know we
also run
the federal
lead paint remediation program
that's
funded by hud and we use the two
sources of funding together in fact we
leverage the state funds roughly
one-to-one with federal funding
the federal the the state funding
based on the
standards that you the legislature
established in 2019 are a bit more
flexible than the federal funding so
there are some properties where
the
that are not eligible for federal
funding that we can use where we can use
the state funding
but generally speaking
most of the uh the work that we do uses
both
federal and state funding in them
i think i'll stop there and be happy to
take any questions
are there any questions uh
representative hatch
thank you madam chair just serious uh
curious i'm sorry if somebody's um to
apply to qualify for a loan does a
mitigation effort have to be total
removal or do you allow encapsulation uh
thank you for that question it's it's a
really great question
removal of lead
would be extraordinarily expensive
that is to strip all of the lead paint
out of a building
would be uh prohibitively expensive and
so
most of the work that is done is
encapsulation
keeping you know safe
covering over the layers or painting so
that you have
high quality durable paint
the issue really with
with lead paint for the most part has to
do with friction and impact surfaces so
windows moving up and down doors opening
and closing it's
we we have this notion based on the um i
remember them the ads from the 1970s
late 70s of of young children eating the
paint you know taking chips of paint
that does happen
but actually more often it's the dust
that you can't see
you can't
feel
but a child simply putting
his or her hand on a windowsill that has
that dust from the window opening and
closing and then putting their fingers
to the mouse
a parent isn't going to see that
but it does happen and that's really
where the great hazard is so
encapsulation is the preferred
alternative
ideally in in a perfect world with
unlimited resources eliminating the lead
entirely from the the
living environment would be great but
it's just too expensive to do
thank you represent petrie
thank you madam sharon thank you for
being here
uh what's the typical length of the
loans that uh you provide for this uh
service
uh uh great question uh they the loans
last as long as the owner owns the
property they there's no term no
specific term
so as long as the owner owns the
property the loan that the lien on the
property resides
with with that property if the owner
sells the property then the loan would
be repaid
thank you
representative debeers
yeah thank you madam chair uh i have a
question for you i mean what criteria
used by huds not to
allocate funds for the units i mean
there's a disparity between what the
state allows for
uh you know for mitigation and what hud
allows what's the difference in the
units
it's a very good question and it's a
simple difference it's one of income
levels so
the federal grant uh requires that the
property be a rental property be uh
occupied by someone uh making uh 80 or
less of median
area median income the state law allows
us to go up to 90 percent of area median
income so that little bit of flexibility
increases the numbers of properties that
are eligible
did you have a follow-up
okay representative walner
thank you
my question is how many child care
providers have accessed the loans
uh again great question um the as
created by the legislature this fund can
be used in
uh
income qualified rental properties
uh income qualified
owner occupied homes or in licensed
daycare centers to remediate the lead
paint hazards there
we have worked with the department of
health and human services
to make the availability of this funding
source known to licensed daycare
facilities
but to date
none of them
have expressed an interest in doing that
i i suspect
that is because in order to get a
license the facility has to be in good
repair which means you wouldn't need to
do the encapsulation of the lead paint i
i that's a guess on my part but i think
it's probably a rational conclusion
patch did you have a follow-up
you're all set
are there any uh representative lin
yes i wonder if you could tell me with
regard to the um the properties that are
not owner occupied that is rented you
you mentioned that there's an income
limit on the tenants
is there any income limit on the owner
of the property there is not
so a
a sort of a large corporation that has
lots and lots of rental units
could qualify for this
that is possible they could qualify but
i'll repeat what i said earlier
most of the units that are have been
remediated using the state funds have
been small owners
we have done
i think a couple of units with
the owner elm grove which is a
large rental property owner in the
manchester area but they're expanding
but very few actually a very small
number of their portfolio thank you
are there any further uh representative
thank you madam chair thank you sir for
being here uh just four really quick
individual questions all related are is
interest paid on the loans no interest
no interest um
and i'm assuming it's a balloon payment
at the end when it's sold yes
uh can the loans ever be forgiven
yes they could be um so
and and that's that would be at um
uh our discretion new hampshire housing
so say for example a
a property owner because of shifts in
the market
what was under water with a mortgage
they didn't have any equity
in the property and they were selling
the property
in that kind of situation we would
forgive the loan
and the final one um
you mentioned a transfer ownership let's
say i owned a four unit and it was in my
wife and i's name and i we decided to
put it into a trust would that qualify
as a transfer that would be a transfer
thank you
representative erf
thank you madam chair
are the federal funds loans or grants
it's a combination but typically done as
loans
and what are the terms of those loans at
the same terms they stay with the
property uh until the property is
transferred and no interest
they that's why these the funds work
really well together
are there any
reps oh sorry representative turcotte
you had your chance
[Laughter]
follow-up
um go ahead
on the forgiven question that you said
yes
have
has uh your department never forgiven
anyone
i
we've only been running the state funded
program for a couple years and i don't
think we've had need to forgive that
we've not been requested to give any
loans i'd have to go back and check to
see if we've forgiven any of the federal
loans okay thank you
representative waltz
okay man i'm
to follow up on what representative lim
hit upon and that is the idea that big
corporations could take advantage of
this if we were to put a limitation in
here eliminating it so that big
corporations you know big residential
groups could not take advantage of it
would that be a problem would that have
create difficult issues for you
i suppose it would depend on
how
the limitations were worded
i and i i i guess i would i would need
to see the language in order to be able
to say whether it would be difficult or
easy
um i i will just say in response to both
your question and representative lynn's
question most of this goes to the the
small scale landowners property owners
thank you for representing that
thank you madam chair along with that uh
train of thought
i don't know that it's relevant
how large the corporation is or how
large or wealthy the entity is that owns
a property the purpose of this program
is to mitigate lead poisoning
in youth and as you stated many times a
proponents of the loans go towards
relatively low rent properties or
section 8 properties or that type of
thing so
um i don't know why that's even matters
it doesn't really add value to the
property that much thank you
i'll i'll take that as a question and
say yes
are there any further questions
i do have one question mr frost and that
is
do you have a waiting list at this point
of
people that are
waiting for this
appropriation
we do i but i regret i don't i don't
know how long that waiting list is
uh what i'll say right now is the um
the program capacity
is limited not by
demand
but by the availability of contractors
so we we could run a bigger program
with more funds
subject to what you choose to to
appropriate
um but the the real limiting factor is
the availability of contractors to do
the work
and and by contractors i mean
contractors who are trained and
certified
to do lead paint remediation which is a
very specialized
narrow field
thank you very much um
seeing no further questions we
appreciate it
and um
i know that uh
division are you having a work session
yeah
uh is having a work session at two
o'clock and it would be
nice if you could join me there thank
you very much
um
this online stuff is really working
i have
that support
the
um
yeah
sb 371
and i have two opposed
and the um
testimony that was sent in
will be available in the bill folder
uh for anyone to uh to look at so
i want to thank the folks that are out
there and hopefully all
58 of these have uh watched what we had
to say today so
uh
thank you and i will close the hearing
oops
sorry i won't close the hearing
um
ryan hale
from new hampshire bankers is in favor
don mckinney
new hampshire legal assistance is in
favor
adam schmidt
new hampshire's association of realtors
and jennifer smith md
uh is also in favor of this bill
so
thank you for attending today
all right now i can close the hearing
all right
it looks like it's uh
1 30
and by the way i really appreciate uh
that
working out to just half an hour
surprisingly
so
i will now open the hearing on senate
bill not 409
senate bill 422
and i see that
representative rosenwald
sorry senator rosenwald
is uh is here to um
introduce the bill
i am thank you thank you madam chair
for the record cindy rosenwald from
senate district 13
nashua i am really happy to introduce
senate bill 422
to add a dental benefit to adults
enrolled in the medicaid program
this bill will add new hampshire to the
list of 35 other states with an adult
dental benefit for
medicaid not only will this benefit
improve the health
of the adult medicaid population it will
also save money upstream in medicaid on
other health treatments right now we
spend millions of dollars on er costs
and emergency extractions which is the
only
current adult benefit along with other
treatments to to fight illnesses
that come along from poor oral health
i would note that this bill is funded
um with most of the centene
settlement money
directed to the benefit
and the the i know that
this committee
worked really hard on house bill 103.
the senate bill's language is a little
different on the sentine settlement
because it includes language
appropriating
2.4 million dollars of the centene
settlement
to repay
cms
on the risk corridor
program and
for details on
exactly why we have to repay cms i would
ask you to ask the department
but the department does need that 2.4
million dollars for that purpose
and um so i hope the committee
will
adopt
this
senate's language
and
as opposed to taking it to what you did
in house bill 103
the senate health committee which has
house bill 103
is also considering
slightly different language on the cost
sharing
that
the house put into house bill 103
and that is to
carve out
preventive and diagnostic services
from the cost sharing
this was suggested by the clinical
dental community and i think it makes
sense
to avoid financial barriers for patients
that could inadvertently
lead to increased unnecessarily
increased
cost of the program
it's i think senator bradley may have
already shared
his language
with this committee
but i have a copy of it with me today if
he hasn't
so those are the two
biggest differences
between the language and senate bill 422
and house bill 103 is amended by the
house
thank you madam chair
you're quite welcome and i
i think our goal is to um
produce one bill that that satisfies
everybody so we're not uh
we're not obviously not opposed to this
because we already
have passed it on the house floor
and so it's just a matter of trying to
work together to
make sure that our languages our
language
relate is is the same
so right okay um
thank you very much senator thank you
i will now call on courtney morin
good afternoon good afternoon uh
courtney i would just like to remind you
that both the house and the senate have
passed a bill
and there's only a very few minor
differences
so we don't need to go into the why
understood okay we all understand the
why
thank you
my name is courtney morin i'm
representing northeast delta dental i'm
an actuary there and i'm here on behalf
of tom raphael our president and ceo
first i'd just like to say thank you to
senator rosenwald representative edwards
and representative er for all your work
on this bill on these two bills to get
them where they are today
um as you heard that i won't go over why
the
the bills are different but i'll just
say that ultimately
while we prefer the senate bill at
northeast delta dental because of the
additional benefits it provides
ultimately we'd be in support of either
house bill 103 or senate bill 422 and
it's just time for us to get these adult
dental benefits a reality
any questions
are there any questions from anyone
sing none thank you courtney appreciate
it
i will now call doug mcnutt nick
is that correct
okay thank you
oh excuse me you need to just press the
there you go
thank you there's a red light what i
need okay the red light's what you need
okay very quickly i just wanted to
introduce myself i'm doug mcnutt i'm
appearing today for the state commission
on aging which is a statutory appointed
up
created commission that is created in
order to review policies of interest to
elders
given that we looked at this bill and
felt it was important obviously for
low-income older adults and we support
the bill and that's all i have to
say thank you are there any questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
i will now call on
garth
corvier
corva
thank you sorry
uh if you would just hand those to kevin
and he'll take care of distribute
yeah
we have very good service in this
committee
as opposed to some of the others
very impressed yeah
um
well uh thank you madam chair uh for the
record my name is garth corvo i'm an
attorney with the bianco professional
association
representing the new hampshire dental
society and its 1100
members uh including dentists and other
dental professionals um
no need to really go through this in
detail i think
for several years the new hampshire
dental society has been on record
working uh through the hb4 working group
to help design this benefit
we've been incredibly pleased with the
work you all have done
in designing
hb 103
the dental society supports both bills
um
you know we think that there are
significant
public health reasons and economic
benefits that will result
uh with the creation of an adult dental
benefit um we also believe
passing that will
have a positive impact on dentist
participation in medicaid which uh very
right now is very low
part of that is because we only have
children's medicaid
and many of the policy changes that you
all have worked on
in house bill 103
uh which you see in this bill
we are confident will increase that
participation level
and it's not just medicaid reimbursement
rates it's also
care coordination minimizing bureaucracy
that sort of thing so
um
so we would just urge uh this committee
and and we're quite uh you know we're
quite confident that
lawmakers from both branches will
collaborate to expeditiously reach a
final bill
if you need
uh if you have any questions uh for any
of new hampshire's dentists
you know we are we're certainly always
willing to work with
this committee and all lawmakers in
um
get finally getting this bill across uh
the finish line and again we're very
grateful for all the work you all have
done in
getting us to this impressive point
thank you are there any questions at all
representative weiler
thank you madam chair
i thought i remembered in 103 a talk
about increasing people's personal
responsibility
in dental care
and i wonder if what you think about
having a co-pay a small co-pay and then
if they don't show up at the dentist
office they owe the money anyway and
won't get another appointment until they
pay it well you you have identified a
very significant issue with
um you know with uh what what would
ultimately face new hampshire's dentists
unlike
you know dentists are very much part of
the healthcare landscape in in in our
state you know the difference between
a doctor and a dentist other than the
work they do is many doctors are part of
a hospital system if a patient doesn't
show up there's always someone coming a
dentist for the most part is a small
business where a patient doesn't come in
they are losing
money as a business
um
and
so i would say that you know whether or
not paying them back you know i'll leave
that for
for you all
but
you've identified
possibly even the most important problem
that dentists would encounter
and that's why we're encouraged by the
care coordination aspect that's really
been what we've been advocating for
um
in the the working group that designed
you know the benefit before you
um
dentists you know it is it is definitely
a concern that they don't want to have
empty chairs they want patients in those
chairs
and um you know we're we're confident in
the bill before you now we you know
we've worked very hard on it um you know
with several of you we're we're happy
with the work this committee did on the
you know the house companion piece
um in terms of the co-pay that you
identified
um the dental society doesn't take a
particular
position on that issue we we understand
the uh policy reasons for doing it
um
we think that simply the fact that there
could be an adult benefit
um will be reason enough for so many you
know tens of thousands of people to
finally get the oral health care they
need
um
you know i know that they're from what
i've heard there's been some discussion
perhaps of removing the copay for
preventative care
um
that i think would
you know i think the preventative care
is just so important getting people in
the door to get their mouths treated
make sure they don't get cavities that
sort of thing oral health disease
i think that would be a
beneficial change to make perhaps
leaving a co-pay for you know the
remaining procedures but to get people
in the door for their checkups for the
preventative care perhaps not having it
for that
we could see that as a as um
as something you could do to him to
improve the bill while still leaving the
co-pay perhaps for
other procedures uh representative
thank you
absolutely
other representative bears
okay thank you madam chairman uh
representative weiler asked the question
that i was very interested in asking
thank you
are there further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you madam chair glad you were able to be
here today
um
our next person is lisa
beaudine
is that sort of right
almost
bowden
okay
good afternoon
madam chair and members of the new
hampshire house finance committee
division three for the record my name is
lisa beaudoin i'm the executive director
of able new hampshire and i want to say
on behalf of our members across the
granite state
allies and the board of directors we
strongly encourage you to support sb422
and more importantly as others have
suggested and as you all have
have
acknowledged
we all need to commit you all need to
commit to passing a benefit program
and funding it for an adult dental
medicaid benefit we need to get this
across the policy finish line as garth
just said it's imperative
that you all continue to work together
the house and the senate to prevent
pursuit of perfection from achieving the
good
let's just get this done i'd like to
also thank representative edwards
representative shapiro senator rosenwald
and senator bradley they have tirelessly
worked
to reach a compromise making this
important policy step forward a reality
able new hampshire's constituents the
disability community are deeply
encouraged to know that an adult dental
medicaid benefit program and its funding
have very strong bipartisan support and
we are very grateful for the tireless
work that has led us to this very day
um
abel has been deeply involved in moving
this bill forward and we know that
sb 422 and hb 103 represent the combined
efforts of many experts elected
officials mcos public and private
providers of oral health care and most
importantly the consumers
right we need to remember that people
are going to be receiving this benefit
who need it
to have teeth so that they can have a
job
because no employer wants to hire
someone with a mouth full of dental
caries
i just wanted to um sum up by saying
that uh identify medicaid dental
adult dental benefit is already state
policy we we made that happen back in
2019 with hb4
it has been able's pleasure to work on
that work group and we are very grateful
that a clear call policy compromise and
understanding will be reached by the new
hampshire house and the new hampshire
senate and i want to thank you all
very much for your commitment to an
adult dental medicaid benefit
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much uh you
indicated you had written testimony
okay would you provide it to kevin
please thank you
okay
i think
that is it
so oh wait no it's not quite
obviously this bill has a lot of
interest around the state
i have
uh
online i have 141
people that support the bill
uh i have four opposed
and we have
28 comments
and as soon as kevin arrives with the
blue sheet
we'll
thank you
uh let's see i have jake barry
new futures in support
don mckenney new hampshire legal
assistance in support
heather carroll
new hampshire aha
jennifer smith
in favor
cathy corey fox harbor care in favor
holly stevens
nami
in favor
uh garth i believe you
uh testified
and i have
representative gabby grossman in favor
so
i thank you all for
attending this meeting and i know that
division three is looking forward to
work on this bill so thank you very much
and have a good afternoon
division one will be a convening at two
o'clock in 212.
tell them the bill number
on
uh two two
two two seven vote and on three three
seven one work session oh for the other
the other
one oh
okay